most important for us is that we will it
will be a win-win
win so it need to be a win to the seller
and we need to understand his motivation
and make sure that he actually doing
fair deal
it need to be win for the company so the
company see us as a long-term partner
and actually we bring value to them and
we can do multiple uh uh transaction and
i can tell you that currently we're
actually doing uh a transaction to you
know in in a company with you know to
many of those the employee so we are
basically exposing the company to the
possibility
to allow
the um the employee to liquidate some of
their shirts and it also need to be win
for us
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community-driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders today we're
talking about the secondary markets meet
draul glass the co-founder of israel's
secondary fund
he co-founded israel's secondary fund
investing in the israeli secondary
market since 2001 with 25 years of
investment experience
previously he was the managing director
at nexus global partners a global
management consulting firm
also former managing director of orama
investments member of the idb group
senior investment manager israel
corporation and the executive director
of the wharton rakhinati program at tel
aviv university
he served on the boards of various
private and public companies both in
israel and abroad registered cpa and
holds a ba in accounting and finance and
an mba in international business and
finance from the university of southern
california
well i'm i'm really excited to have you
here and draw a glass from israel's
secondary fund talking about a whole
part of the market on the whole part of
the ecosystem that
it's it's not necessarily that it's not
too much spoken about but i think it may
be a little even a little bit
misunderstood a little bit
underrepresented
and um and it requires another layer of
understanding into what's happening in
order to understand the different
potential uh avenues to go there and so
i'm really happy that you're here to to
share a little bit about your own
journey and a little bit about
secondaries with me so welcome jor thank
you very much and again thank you for
the invitation i'm very happy to be here
secondary as a market what is first of
all to level the playing field what is a
secondary deal or a secondary investment
in in high level okay so we actually
doing three times of transaction or the
secondary market is actually divided
into three type of transaction
is buying a p positions in other funds
by minority stakes in technology
companies or in general in companies
that's what we call secondary direct and
what we call gp led is those funds at
reaching the terms and most of them
actually need to extend their terms so
we allow some of the lp uh
to basically liquidate their position
and extending the fund if required also
raising a little bit or adding more
capital to support the existing
portfolio in general i would say the
secondary market is basically creating
liquidity in illiquid market
and it's basically by that actually
propelling the growth and increase the
efficiency of the market and i'm very
very happy that we're actually reaching
the stage
where um you know from a niche market
will become integral part of the market
and today there is no single person in
the tech ecosystem in israel that i need
to explain what is a secondary
in most companies in most fund will have
multiple secondary transaction uh over
the their lifetime
right and so really to accomplishing
this is this idea of creating liquidity
and an illiquid market
now this this idea of secondary is how
big is it really in the in the tech
world because because really we don't
hear too much of this in the news and we
don't get exposed too much of what's
happening but if you can just give me a
little bit about the scope of of where
we're at today
um in terms of secondaries i think
they'll be helpful so the global
secondary market is about 100 billion
dollars the large groups are ardian
caller lexington uh goldman sachs
and others
um
the sub segment and the very small part
of it is actually uh what we call tech
secondary some other or exactly venture
secondary and i you know venture at all
is less than ten percent of the world
secondary market so the one secondary um
the whole venture secondary globally is
about i would assume something like
10 billion dollars so it's actually
niche market either the whole and most
secondary players globally are doing
very limited uh secondary and most of
them
doing limited amount of secondary in the
vc world most of them will do lp
position and if they will do secondary
direct they will do it in a late stage
companies um
very very few are doing an early stage
and growth stage um
companies in in the in the court in
general
and and so so why i mean what's the
friction for you know anybody to come in
and do secondary stage investments in
early and growth stage companies tech
companies you know i think actually it's
a very very different
evaluations of
companies
um it require very specific
um knowledge and expertise
and very very deep uh rooted into the
market you know part of the reason we
are doing only israeli related assets is
really not enough only to understand
what the company is doing and analyzing
the global potential you also need to
understand deeply the internal um uh
notion of the company so you do need to
turn on routes into those specific
companies and if you're buying a
portfolio you do need to have a
valuation of the underlying asset by by
you know each of those assets
differently it's a very very different
comparing to private equity
or uh you know buyout funds
and so does this mean that it requires
different sets of information and
requires deeper due diligence i mean
where's what's really the
the jump that one needs to make in order
to become active
you know in the secondary market like
you have with israel's secondary fund
the idea is that you need to have a deep
root into the market understand you know
many different uh um on markets you need
to have the relationship that actually
access those companies and to be a
trusted partner take into consideration
that um in private equity most of the
cases you have a controlling entity that
basically run the ship
um in the vc world you have a group it's
actually it's a club investment there
are great book for investors that
actually in most cases you'll see at
least six investors in each company
different one you know from agent
investors to to early state vcs uh you
know to vc to late vc to growth and some
private equity um in many cases exactly
would be multiple in each stages so it's
actually group so you do need to
understand the company you do need to
understand the market and you also need
to have the relationship with the
investments and you be and you need to
be trusted by all those parties in order
to be able to
access and invest in those companies
so we're talking about trust a and
you've already mentioned trusts
in a few ways here what it tell me just
a little bit about trust and and when it
comes to secondary investment so if
maybe even from the from the company's
perspective and let's let's focus the
conversation on tech in israel from a
company's perspective how do they see
a secondary deal what is sort of their
view and i think that it's also
worthwhile considering a little bit
about you know the
how it looks right i mean because you
effectively have from my understanding
you have an active player coming in and
replacing a portion of another active
player what does this mean about the
company what does this mean about the
trust in the company right it has a lot
of these different more philosophical
intuitive questions
what what's happening give me some give
me some order you know i i always say
that you know substantial thought or you
know a large part of what we do is that
we have a lot of psychologists so there
is
people are selling so you first need to
understand why what's the motivation for
the seller to say
and let's actually take the situation
that you are 35 you're still not 35 but
35 years old um a founder owning
10 percent of a company that worth
50 million dollars if he will sell his
position
uh it's a life changer for him but he
has actually misalignment with his
employees because they want him to
continue and he want you know the
investors want him to continue and the
investors of these investors actually
want him to continue
so by creating by allowing to sell a
little bit
of what he does like 20 percent let's
call it um he can actually reduce to his
risk
uh improve his stand of the living
um and
continue to show confidence in the
company and increase the alignment
between him and the other stakeholders
so think about that actually when we
went through um market education that
you know like
i would say seven years ago if a ceo
would sell to us 20 of his state it
would consider that he actually have a
low degree of belief in his company
today's exactly right
the vc will be the one that he will
approach us and will recommend us to
speak with the founder and will try to
include stability to sell to us part of
his stake in order to increase the
alignment between the vc
and the management so the the um
the psychology behind it is actually try
to understand the motivation
you do need to understand the different
position of the different stakeholders
and they also need to accept you as a
value bed for long term in um you know
as part of the shareholders and actually
i want to mention here that basically
you know as a fund with a deep pocket so
we enter as a secondary in a secondary
transaction but after we actually
investing we are basically becoming as
any other fund and we will continue
investing in full on grounds and will
continue to do it additionally secondary
uh which actually opened a lot of
opportunity for this specific company
and
the uh um
in this specific fund so it's
interesting effectively what you're
mentioning is that
there there is a psychological shift and
and what it means to approach a
secondary deal where if before the
the default was that you know some
people want to get rid let's use the
word red as a negative connotation get
rid of their shares or their stake
because they they foresee that their
shares are not going to be as valuable
later on right that's the motivation now
you're saying well actually now that the
motivation is different now the
motivation is that the people on the
inside are have
intuition to what's happening and and
they can see that what's happening with
the company and they actually you know
more from the investment side the
other vcs they're approaching and saying
listen there's this amazing company here
the founders have a significant amount
of shares maybe there could be an
interesting deal and we don't have to go
through the formal process of raising an
entire round of
providing a new valuation and doing all
of that
difficult process that that founders you
know have to do
you know in general the secondary deal
with us required you know um
uncomparable resources compared to vc or
growth you know our due diligence is
very we actually since we actually
coming late to the game so we are
basically really relying on the
information that comes right just end
with conversation with other investors
in most most important for us is that we
will it will be a win-win
win so it need to be a win to the seller
and we need to understand his motivation
and make sure that he actually doing
fair deal beam it need to be win for the
company so the company see us as a
long-term partner and actually we bring
value to them and we can do multiple uh
uh transaction and i can tell you that
currently we're actually doing uh a
transaction to you know in a company
with you know too many of those the
employee
so we are basically exposing the company
to the possibility to allow the uh the
employee to liquidate some of their
shirts and it also need to be win for us
uh so ours is also going to be benefit
so it's always need to be win-win-win
um that's actually part of our uh i
would say moto in the front
okay so so taking taking me back a
little bit to the the founding of of
israel's secondary fund and i'm curious
also to hear a little bit about the
perception change
throughout you know your your time
talking about secondaries because
growing up i i'm perhaps i had more of
an old-school thought process behind
what a secondary deal is and every time
i saw the word secondary i was like ah
well something something here isn't
ideal or isn't you know on the ideal
path for this company but i'm actually
you know through this conversation i'm
changing my mindset as to what what a
secondary deal could mean so share with
me a little bit about the founding of
israel's secondary fund and and what's
happening now
you know the actually i i actually been
exposed to the secondary worlds in
general 2001 when i was actually looking
for a diversified strategy
um you know i have
very close plans among the bc and growth
funds
in israel and i like many of them very
much and i think actually they're doing
very you know they become highly
professional and actually doing very
well i was looking for something which
is actually different
uh today something which is actually
diversified
and i can tell you that actually from
2001 i basically involved in the
secondary market so it's for a long time
and actively from 2008 i'm actually
investing in the secondary market um and
for a long time we actually
had to do a market education for you
it's obvious if you are
um owning um a shares of up um of uh
of amazon or your
or shared of the checkpoint it's obvious
for you that you are allowed to sell
build shares
right why if you are owning the shares
of uh
verbit or adork
you cannot actually um sell those shares
there is no reason for you
um to hold those shares if it's actually
a major part of your asset for 12 years
and actually initially takes between
eight to 13 years so it's a very very
long journey
um for many of us it's actually going to
be a major
asset for us and actually make
uh it makes a lot of data a sense to
diversify and actually reduce your
exposure to a single asset
so we actually had to went through a a
process or a
term of actually educating the market
that it's actually it's okay for you to
say
now what happens is that you know after
market education and the acceptance in
the market it's become
really become kind of the standard
that you know employees and founders and
early stage investors should be allowed
to sit um and that's actually the stage
where we actually can't
right and i and obviously you have
different startups like equity b and and
the and a variety of more in the in the
space that are that are looking at this
question of what what do what do shares
of a private company mean and it sounds
like that it's not just the market
market education that it's okay that
it's possible to
to exercise
your shares or to or to liquidate it's
also a question of how to do it i mean
you know right now um
if you had to ask me what are the
different ways that i can potentially
do a secondary or act on a secondary
deal either as a founder or as an
investor
my options are pretty limited i don't
have that many that i can think to mind
of of what i can do or who i can
approach which i think is a part of the
problem that you're representing and and
the opportunity that you have with
israel's secondary fund as a group that
is well known that has established that
there is trust that has a process for
doing this and has learned how to do
this properly what were sort of the big
milestones for israel's secondary fund
throughout your throughout your lifetime
um
you know actually first i want actually
to um
to make sure that we understand that
actually i highly appreciate uh um
equity b and i think actually they are
bringing tremendous value and i think
there is a room for what they do equity
b is a platform that basically a match
between a seller and a buyer
and in many cases they will do the
transaction with a very limited
information
we are an investment fund so we will not
do any transaction without specific
cooperation from the management of the
company in full
uh um information
and more
once we actually entered the company and
actually did our initial investment
through secondary we will continue to do
transaction and i can tell you that you
know there are companies that we did
five and six
secondary transactions along the way to
many of the employees and banks and
founders and others
and we will continue in full on
investment so it's a we are the pure
fund that once you're actually replacing
it you know um a seller with a limited
resources
with a fund that can continue to support
you not only financially also through
our uh you know deep understanding of
the of the ma the market and the global
network that we have in those company
even in this so it's an important
distinction because you're saying and
you're reminding and it's an important
thing to reiterate because of the
perhaps a perception of what a secondary
deal is but you're saying there is this
it's a triangle it's not a two-way
street between you and the seller it is
you the seller and the company it's the
trajectory of the company and the goal
is to then you know long term if you if
you take a few years from the initial
investment it doesn't really matter
whether you came in through a secondary
or through a direct investment like
another venture capital fund did because
you are as involved as a traditional
player on the cap table of this company
and this is an important distinction to
make yeah we are
involved but we are not as involved as
vc and growth so we are not sitting on a
board we are not coming to america we
want to make sure that we have alignment
of interest with the company management
and with the other investors and we will
do model
transaction along the way
and so israel secondary funds if you had
to look at where you're at today in
terms of the landscape a little bit
about the plans forward
um you know i can say that you know vcn
growth um as i said you know i think
actually i'm adding a huge value into
the market
uh but the secondary is by far the most
creative
uh part of the private equity and i can
tell you that if 10 years ago only the
only thing we did is nlp positions
today we provide liquidity um to the
investors
to the companies to the funds and to the
investors of the fund so we became very
very creative in the way we actually
doing business today
um and if you think about it actually we
are basically bridging the gap between
the different stages of companies
so we allow the company and management
to um
you know push forward and actually build
much larger um companies um today
compared to
in the past so we actually propelling
growth and actually adding substantial
uh efficiency into this mod
fantastic and if you're looking at the
secondary market in general
as it transitions and as it grows just
you know just a little bit about picking
your brain as to what what's expected
for us is there are there are there many
shifts that we still need to make any
big leaps that have yet to be uncovered
in the secondary market or the way that
secondary market works
um what is actually interesting to see
that you actually see today that many
of my colleagues actually also doing
second
um and the main reason is because
secondary has become integral part of
this market
um and we will see more and more and
actually i i anticipate that we will
continue to see if this market in israel
alone
um more
than triple in the last decade i'm
actually continue to see a very strong
growth in this market uh going forward
at least in the three to five years to
come
i love it well you know this is exactly
why i i started this podcast and the
show and two
take a subject that i i honestly don't
know very much about and and spend 20
minutes shifting my rewiring you know my
transistors a little bit so that i can
think about it differently and i can
have more curiosity to dive into it and
so i definitely know what i'm going to
be spending a little bit of my time on
today looking into it and it sounds even
some interesting reading if you actually
if you want i'll be more than happy to
send you some instant review please send
me your uh contact and i'll send you um
tons of stuff and i think actually it's
interesting and in general think about
what is the uh um you know the the uh
creativity of ebay
ebay is actually taking its expensive uh
um
um table that actually i bought and the
moment after i bought it actually was
nothing
basically creating like a virtual market
where buyer and seller actually can meet
and that's basically what is the
secondary market we actually created a
virtual a market for tech
uh e-liquid assets can which are very
complicated and they are very limited
amount of buyers and actually created
efficiency in this market
i love it
thank you very much and best of luck
with israel secondary fund
looking for some exciting news in the
future and uh best of luck thank you for
sharing your time with me thank you very
much i really appreciate it wonderful
you